Let's take a look at beta first just because it has smaller numbers,
so maybe that's a bit easier to reason about.
Now, as we grow the input size, notice that we're going the input size the linear way.
And as we grow linearly, the time it takes beta also grows relatively linearly.
So we double from 100 to 200, we roughly double as we triple from 100 to 300,
and we get roughly triple of the initial input size.
16 is pretty close to 18, so I'm going to go ahead and say that beta is linear.
Now, alpha just explodes--at 100, it doesn't take a whole lot of timing,
that takes quite a bit less time in gamma but at N=200,
alpha is already in the hundreds of thousands and then
it gets even bigger and bigger very very quickly.
So I think it's reasonable to say that alpha has an exponential running time.
Now, gamma might be a little trickier to see, by I think,
if you look at the input sizes relative to the running times in gamma,
we can see that it looks to be polynomial.
To see this, let's take a look at N² for this input sizes.
N² for 100 is 10⁴ which is quite a bit bigger than gamma's running time.
N² for 200 is similarly much bigger than gamma's running time and on and on.
N² is really the lowest polynomial running time you are probably going to get that it is linear?
And it definitely dominates gamma at least for the instances that we are looking at.
So, I will definitely say that gamma is polynomial in running time.
For more visual representation of this, let's draw a few graphs.
Let's take a look at alpha first.
Now alpha is still very tiny at N=100 and relative to this graph it is still very tiny here.
Here it's quite a bit bigger but still compared to the 10¹³,
10⁹ is actually pretty small and then it's way up here for any of this, 400.
Let's just kind of draw an approximation to that.
This is not a scale but it'll give you an idea for the shape of the graph
which is really what we're going for.
But in gamma, we really just can't see them on this graph.
They are so close to the x axis here that they might as well just be right on top of it.
So that doesn't really help us.
So clearly alpha is growing just unbelievably faster than both beta and gamma.
So let's zoom in a bit and look at this again.
All right, so now I'm only going up to 10⁴, so that makes gamma fairly easier to draw
and if this on 100 still, pretty small. At 200, it's closer.
At 300, it is about half way there and then it gets about here. So let's go ahead and draw it up.
If we try to draw beta, it's still right about here, so it still grows much much slower than gamma does.
As we can see that they're really in different classes because they're both just growing so much slower
than alpha is, but beta similarly is growing just so much slower than gamma is.
So they're definitely in different classes and this is kind of a visual intuitive representation
of why alpha is exponential, gamma is polynomial, and beta is linear.